on Prime crime did she ever talk to you
about running away
a nine-year-old's disappearance do you
have any any idea where this girl may be
I wish I know becomes a search for the
truth
I'm gonna do everything in my power come
on
[Music]
hi to everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
break down the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases
crimes against children they're some of
the most disturbing and heinous in our
society and as you're about to see
getting to the bottom of what happened
in these situations is sometimes no
simple task
s
the woman you're seeing is 23 year old
ebony Wiley as she sits in a Florida
police station she's being asked about
her neighbor nine-year-old Felicia
Williams
me and how I'm hungry you guys know her
as Felicia we knew her as sugar plum
that was our sugar plum she was amazing
she was very like a vibrant child very
sweet she's very loving very caring
funny but why are police asking about
Felicia let's take a step back there's a
chance meeting between Wiley and a
stranger that set this whole case in
motion
I
would say
200 a week I've worked driving and I saw
her and I put it over I said can I talk
to you this is 35 year old Granville
Ritchie a Jamaican immigrant who went by
the name Trevor I talked to her on the
phone later on and then we hooked up
later on this total stranger that just
kind of plops down he actually met her
while
he was driving down the road ebony
actually fell in love with Granville
like from the moment that she saw him
Wiley then says she confided in Richie
about some issues Felicia was having
namely her getting into trouble and
showing up unannounced at Wiley's new
job that's what I call my friend can you
call Trevor and I say
um
you remember I was telling you about my
God baby why I want you to be like yeah
I was like
I want to go over there and book with a
belt because she wouldn't be in the
house like no
just do it the right way you know let's
find her something to eat
talk to her that way just a few days
into their new love affair the couple
decided to get together and take Felicia
out so Trevor came over to picked you up
I picked up at her house did she telling
her mom where you work no exactly where
we were just because I remember to trust
in me and then you drove right from
there to Checkers Cafe home we won
Checkers my true Checkers a lot of the
food we wrote food we went by over with
my moms their narratives and their
stories matched up almost like a hand
and a glove they drive to Richie's
mother's apartment in nearby Temple
Terrace but a short time later Wiley and
Richie explained how things turned
horribly wrong we were there too of
course me and the girl is gonna get
private you know what I mean before we
go to the room I put a movie you
watching it metal down we chilling we
going in room
go ahead and take a shower get a shower
they went in there and began to have
sexual intercourse on his mother's bed
that night
as soon as I opened up this girl on my
own couch and we came out of that room
man that little girl was gone both
Richie and Wiley contend that when they
came out of this bedroom having been
quote unquote intimate with one another
that this child this nine-year-old child
had vanished Into Thin Air the balcony
in the oven
or from now I went back anymore I said
this girl is gone you did pondering
pondering pondering she's like call the
cops
praying I said come home this girl don't
put anybody in any problem we gotta look
forward we got to look for when I first
got the call from my mom she was like
sugar plum missing can you help me find
her I'm not no I'm not helping you she's
not she's not missing I know sugar plum
is not missing she is on her bike
somewhere at a friend house and she'll
be home soon as the time went by and I
was telling my cousin I'm like this just
don't feel right coming up investigators
desperately search for answers where is
Felicia Williams where do you think she
is
mysteriously
she didn't get somebody else over there
Apartments
[Music]
this ain't right something wrong this
little girl don't walked out the door
in May 2014 nine-year-old Felicia
Williams disappeared Without a Trace she
was last seen with her former neighbor
ebony Wiley and Wiley's Newfound love
interest Jamaican immigrant Granville
Trevor Richie at his mother's apartment
not far from where the girl lived police
bring Wiley and Richie in for
questioning but the clock is ticking and
investigators need answers on where
Felicia might be how long were you in
your room with Trevor before you came
out
what do you know about this guy
and like it was like oh what's the name
it was the last name how could you come
bring this child to someone house and he
rips up Norm right away not too much
what's I think very striking is the fact
that these two had essentially known
each other for a total of three days I
don't know what she was thinking in her
mindset what I feel truly happened is
that she went with someone who made a
bad judgment and he couldn't have
because
you know that for sure do I know for
sure yes sir you were with him every
second of time
yes in here the door open or closed or
unlocked do you hear anybody talking
anything
no did she ever talk to you about it
running away final times do you think
that she could have walked home from
there she probably could have this child
had never been to this location we can
all remember back to when we were nine
how maybe fearful of the world you were
around you and the one person that kind
of connects you to some level of safety
in Felicia's case at least was ebony why
would Felicia suddenly abandon that kind
of Port that kind of Harbor of safety
when she's in a strange environment all
of a sudden she's just gonna walk out of
the door good any any idea where this
girl may be man I wish I know the
interview continues but then Wiley says
something very curious did he tell you
to say that he wasn't there to say that
his mom was there yeah say it was my mom
with you I said well okay and that's why
I said I was in a shower but she was in
Hawaii
I can't escape I don't want to make it
feel like I was an unfit godmother
you've got a nine-year-old girl missing
wouldn't you want to do everything that
you possibly could to give them the
facts in this case so it's this poor
child could be recovered brought back to
those that love her somebody probably
say I would grow wandering around and
just things
come together if anything happens to her
we have to make sure that we can you
know
somebody's got to be brought to Justice
move what happens next turns the
investigation upside down we was all at
my mom house chief of police and then
also a few detective and police officers
they started walking up the sidewalk
really fast then once he walked in the
house he spoke to my mom he said I'm
gonna do everything in my power to make
sure we find whoever did this and my mom
just broke and fell
and then from there that's when we knew
it's something bad happened a day after
Felicia went missing her naked body is
found floating in Tampa Bay forensic
authorities would conclude that she had
been repeatedly hit in the head sexually
assaulted and strangled to death you
have a body that is essentially
deposited in water this individual knew
that they had done something wrong they
knew that they had left potentially
behind trace evidence the water is going
to wash away any kind of physical
Remnant that's there the mother trusted
in Ebony Wiley to look after her child
and then ultimately this horrible crime
occurs and this is when Wiley's story
starts to shift when she talks to
investigators later on some details of
her account are the same but this time
she says she wants to tell the whole
truth
that's when he got up and was not gone
you've got a witness who has given a
couple of different stories and probably
the police are beginning to think can we
actually trust what she is saying
because she's key to all of this please
yeah he was like okay you gotta go I
won't say yeah I like um
going with me he said oh well
um
um I don't think she should go because
you know you're about a license and you
know you better have weed in the car so
I think you should say she was so
blinded by what she saw in Granville
Richie that she was literally literally
willing to leave her with him yeah that
we
um
when I got to the game I'm calling him
call him call him
I was like open up the door I'm at the
door he was like come on I'm not in the
house I'm at CVS he said this little
girl at the stove she don't gone now
with another possible scenario in the
mix investigators need to figure out
what really happened the day Felicia
disappeared
man he probably did something
oh he probably did nothing to that
little girl
[Music]
oh
did Trevor ever talk to you and give you
any any information that would lead you
to believe that he did anything at all
that
no sorry it's May 2014 and police are
investigating The Disappearance of
nine-year-old Felicia Williams who was
spending time with her former neighbor
ebony Wiley and Wiley's new love
interest Granville Trevor Ritchie at his
mother's apartment the couple says
Felicia vanished as they were getting
intimate since Wiley and Richie were
seemingly the last two people to see
Felicia they're interviewed by police
yet the child's dead body is ultimately
found floating in Tampa Bay ebony Wiley
tells investigators that her initial
stories were lies and then explains that
she went to buy drugs but when she
returned Felicia was gone he called me
like where you at where you at I was
like I'm better than these DBS she's not
uphill he was like come back to the
house come back to the house and come
pick me up come pick me up from the
house
okay when I was driving up I look up he
got his shirt off I just used pens and
bosses this necklace his hat when she
returned
Granville Richie was shirtless
and he was sweating profusely
and he was he was actually stating
child Felicia was gone I was like what
happened he was like man as soon as you
left she asked she asked me to um do I
have Ken I told her no she was like well
can you give me two dollars to go to the
store I was like well how she know it's
CVS around here and he was like oh no I
told her that she could go to CVS I sat
down he panicking he panicked and he
panicking and I was like just calm down
calm down say I've been put in God's
hands he said those who pray in secretly
he shall reward you openly
detective show Wiley photos of the
apartment to see if she notices anything
that might be out of place and that's
when she mentions a few interesting
observations
[Music]
living clothes here and it was closed in
the suitcase
see that wasn't right there all these
clothes were serious you see his power
right here it was lined up and that's
how to close off it was almost as if
someone had opened a suitcase that
contained clothing and essentially
dumped them out in a hurry any right
thinking investigator would want to know
well what was the hurry about what was
the frenzy about anything else in that
picture oh Jesus
that's his transfer him what are you
talking about right here isn't that
different yeah that was drag marks on
the surface of the floor that police
believe were consistent
with a suitcase it was leaving a tiny
little indention Wiley has also shown
pictures of Richie's car where she
notices something else
here with that car
it's okay
when he dropped me off home everything
begins to kind of come into Focus
because now you know that you've got a
suitcase that was used essentially as a
conveyance and ultimately as a very very
poor coffin for this child and that's
not all the cell phone records and data
was critical it placed Richie in the
area where the body was disposed one of
the samples that was found attached to
Granville Richie's car was was referred
to as a white Mangrove leaf that
particular species of plant actually was
in place pretty much immediately
adjacent to the causeway where we
believe Felicia's body was deposited
from there was a very specific type of
sand that is associated with this area
as well that was found also contained
within his car after an extensive
investigation by police Granville Richie
is arrested in charge with first-degree
murder sexual battery and aggravated
child abuse
as for Ebony Wiley she herself faced
charges for providing false information
to police serious charges for a serious
crime but is there enough evidence to
prove Richie is Felicia's killer there
was no evidence no evidence at all that
he had scratch marks on him or that he
had bruises on him at all that might be
associated with Felicia attempting to
fend him off in any way there's also
been talk of why was her DNA not found
in the car
[Music]
I said do you think that we should call
the police he was like no no because I
don't want the police come check at my
house
in September 2019 the Florida trial of
Granville Richie began this was the man
accused of sexually assaulting and
murdering nine-year-old Felicia Williams
five years earlier prosecutors allege
Williams neighbor ebony Wiley left the
girl with Richie whom she had recently
become romantically involved with a
decision that ended in tragedy he put
his hands around the throat
strangle her and then he took Felicia's
lifeless nude body
and he threw it like someone would throw
a bag of garbage into the cold dark
Waters
of Tampa Bay
Felicia Williams wife
meant less to this man
than his sexual desires to violate her
the prosecution tied Richie to the crime
through forensics cell phone data his
questionable police interview and their
key witness ebony Wiley why is it that
you ask Rambo are you responsible did
you do something to her because she
didn't show up if she walked away if she
don't ran down the street she gonna show
up I believe Wiley was a important if
not crucial witness for the prosecution
she filled in the gaps I told him that a
lot and it was like what you lied about
I said I love her with Trevor and he
wanted me to go and get some weed for
him
and then when I came back
she wasn't there
when it came to the defense they
highlighted a lack of physical evidence
it's not crystal clear that Granville
Richie harmed Felicia Williams when
Felicia Williams is missing
there's no science of a struggle in that
apartment
there's no DNA evidence left by Felicia
Williams that you would expect no hair
no skin nothing they even suggested
there wasn't clear proof of what
happened to Felicia do you see any
evidence
in the autopsy report and the
photographs that would suggest to you
that a sexual assault sexual battery had
taken place in this case no defense
counsel put forth that the injuries that
Felicia sustained may very well have
come about as a result of the body as it
floated in Tampa Bay bumping up against
rocks it's absolutely outlandish that
area of the body is very well protected
yet before the case was handed over to
the jury prosecutors had one last thing
up their sleeve a brief but very
important 9-1-1 phone call something
happened that many believe struck fear
Into the Heart of this child she was
able they believed to get her hands on
Granville Richie's phone
[Music]
she punched in the numbers nine one one
the call only lasted for a short period
of time but somebody disconnected that
call I doubt it was her it's an
indication of not just Felicia's
torturous end
but it's an indication I think at the
end of the day in her bravery
of the first degree murder as charged
Richie is found guilty on all counts
including first degree murder sexual
battery and aggravated child abuse it
was a win she was everything
and for him this guard her life she was
nothing like no one would never fire her
cause for her it means so much to us he
discarded her like she was trash he
deserves it like he deserve everything
that's coming to him and that certainly
wasn't the end of the story for
Granville Richie
my name is Granville Richie should be
sentenced to death yes as for Ebony
Wiley she pleaded guilty to lying to
police and would end up sentenced to
just 75 days in jail I think ultimately
prosecutors didn't have anything or
enough to charge her with the actual
death because she wasn't necessarily
involved I feel like her sentence was a
slap on her wrist she was the main
reason to why we're here it's very
unfair but it's understand that's how
the system works
is definitely experience no one should
have to go through it just makes you
more of aware of everyone you know
intentions when they come around your
children
it makes you more of aware
because you just never know you you
never know
the search for the truth in the
Granville Richie case was definitely
complicated and when that truth finally
came out it devastated a family
investigators and prosecutors though
were able to get Justice for Felicia and
it is justice that will last because at
the time of this recording the Florida
Supreme Court has officially upheld
Richie's death sentence
thanks for joining us here on Prime
crime until next time stay safe
[Music]
thank you